i know i seem really tough but i am
afraid of heights yeah
one thing i'm afraid of action heroes
and huge stars
might seem like they live their lives
with absolutely no fear
but it turns out that even the biggest
celebs aren't brave about
everything that's right a ton of actors
are stricken with some very serious
phobias
but the best ones never let that stand
in the way of their dream job
even if their dream job is deep
underwater or
at the top of a terrifyingly tall
building these amazing actors pushed
through their phobias and conquered them
for their most
iconic roles i'm really glad that i went
through the process of auditioning
because i felt like okay
i really i earned this now you might
think that someone who has been an
a-list celebrity since they were 9 years
old like
emma watson fears nothing but when it
came time to audition for belle in
beauty and the beast
one huge fear almost made her throw in
the towel
singing emma hadn't sung since she was
12
and was absolutely terrified of having
to sing in front of anyone
let alone millions and millions of fans
she
even hated doing karaoke that was mildly
terrifying
but knowing that her dream job was on
the line she leaned into her fear
challenged herself and completely
conquered you know i wish i could say it
was
a little fluffy to do but it was that
intense if we already had a fear of
tight enclosed spaces
we probably wouldn't jump at the chance
to make a movie about being buried alive
but that's exactly what ryan reynolds
did in 2010's buried
if you don't remember the entire movie
takes place inside a sealed coffin
with reynolds trapped inside during the
shoot he has said that he actually had
safe words that he would shout to be
pulled out if he needed it
but the majority spanish-speaking crew
didn't always understand
and would leave him in there during a
panic attack the shoot was so rough that
he says he was both physically
and emotionally changed after filming
finished and the last day of shooting
was
uh was unlike anything i've ever
experienced in my life
even though anthony mackey's marvel
character falcon does
a lot of flying it turns out that the
actor actually has one huge fear of his
own
heights yup that means that every time
he had to soar through the air
or leap off of a tall building he was
totally terrified
every single time one time he even had
to leap off of a bridge and land
right on top of a car sure he had wires
to make sure he lived through the
experience
but it definitely wasn't easy oh yeah i
mean like we learned horse riding i
don't know if you've done it before
but yeah robert pattinson had to
interact with a lot of animals for the
2011 film
water for elephants but it wasn't the
giant elephants that made him nervous
it was the horses it turns out that the
actor has a long-standing fear of horses
and one scene in particular freaked him
out the most
in it he had to get knocked over by a
full-grown stallion
and he did not have a good time on set
that day
terrified of riding rusty i hate it
apparently fear of horses runs in the
twilight family
because rob's co-star kristen stewart
also hates being around the four-legged
giants
during snow white and the huntsman she
knew that she was going to have to learn
to ride
and was completely terrified at the
thought even though she took lessons and
worked with some of the best trainers in
the world
she never really got over her fear and
said that she never wanted to ride again
after the shoot was over you're afraid
of heights
everyone's afraid of something shailene
woodley has said that she is very afraid
of heights
but actually loves leaning into her
fears in order to get the adrenaline
rush that she loves
so when it came time to climb to the top
of a ferris wheel in chicago for
divergent
she ran into the challenge head-on even
though she was freezing cold and very
uncomfortable
she loved the experience and used that
fear to help push herself to the top
the scariest thing i did i did a 20-foot
free-fall
jump rebel wilson might be completely
fearless when it comes to her comedy
but when it comes to heights that is an
entirely different story
so in pitch perfect 3 when she and anna
kendrick had to do a 20-foot free-fall
she needed a little help from her friend
according to rebel anna would sing to
her every time they got hoisted
up before the fall and what did she sing
well have a listen
she's like going to the chat
emma roberts is hollywood royalty but
that doesn't mean that she isn't human
just like the rest of us
and when she was young her stage fright
was so bad that she almost didn't land
her breakout role as addie singer and
unfabulous
she was way too afraid to sing in public
but found comfort in the safety of a
film set
even now she says she could never do a
play or a live musical because she is
too nervous to perform on stage
your mind knows that it's not real but
your body doesn't know that you're not
going through something really awful
sarah paulson's real-life fear is so
strange and intense that ryan murphy
actually decided to write it into the
storyline of american horror story cult
in this season paulson's character and
sarah herself
suffer from something called trypophobia
which is actually the fear of small
clusters of holes
and while it might sound strange to some
of us it turns out that around 16
percent of people suffer
the same fear it's the whole
thing
with this movie there was one well there
was one thing that i ended up having to
do but i didn't want to do it
we usually see aubrey plaza as someone
who doesn't care what other people think
but because her character in the to-do
list would be seen in all kinds of
compromising positions she was downright
terrified
so much so that every single day of
shooting brought up a new wave of
serious anxiety
luckily she was able to rely on the
support of her director and castmates to
help her get through some of the most
adult situations
for her oscar-nominated turn in the
harrowing movie cake
jennifer aniston had to face one of her
biggest fears
going underwater see when jen was only
five years old
she accidentally drove her tricycle into
her family pool and sunk
all the way to the bottom after that the
idea of being submerged in water became
her biggest fear
and it took her over 30 takes to work up
the courage to let herself sink
underwater on set
who was the most freaked out about
having to shoot that scene matt damon
matt damon has played all kinds of
action heroes
but it turns out that his biggest fear
in the world is snakes
maybe he should give indiana jones a try
i
hate snake shark i hate him scarlett
johansson revealed that while filming
their heartwarming film we bought a zoo
damon actually cried a little bit when
faced with the idea of handling the
slithery creatures
but because the kids in the film and
skarjo insisted he wound up working with
the snakes and facing his biggest fear
my legs didn't work i was just like
even though she gave matt damon a hard
time for being afraid of snakes
scarlett johansson has a funny animal
phobia of her own
birds the actress has said that she
really doesn't like their
beaks and wings and the way that they
move really creep her out
but in we bought a zoo she had to
overcome her phobia to film scenes
around lots of birds
the ones that she refused to go near
however peacocks
so fun working with animals scarlett
isn't the only celeb with an aversion to
the big winged creatures either
even though jake gyllenhaal didn't go
into prince of persia with a fear of
ostriches
by the time he left it was a full-on
phobia
ostrich racing the handlers reminded him
one too many times not to make noise
near the big birds
because they could tear out your eyes
and rip out your heart
so when it came time to film the scene
where he is chased by a pack of them
the fear in his eyes was all real
for someone who was starred in movies
like charlie and the chocolate factory
and alice in wonderland
it seems odd that johnny depp would be
afraid of clowns
but he is the actor had to face his fear
while filming both charlie and the
chocolate factory and alice in
wonderland
how does he deal with his fear in the
most johnny depp way possible
by surrounding himself with clown
paraphernalia to ward off the evil
why not you know what if these celebs
can face their biggest fears
like shailene woodley climbing to the
very top of a ferris wheel
it makes us feel like we can do the same
though
you know maybe tomorrow
but we want to know what is your biggest
fear that you would face for your dream
[Music]
job